alors vous partez sur une île déserte
préférez une fille très laide ou un mec
très beau je préfère une fille puis même
la ddt away ah oui d'accord mais un vrai
terreau jean marie messier d'affréter
robella meçabih natation circonstances
atténuantes vous donner le plus de
circonstances atténuantes à vesoul qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui
tapent sur des vieilles un lieu qui se
trame du type nous préparer pour
hollywood non mais l'autre bien alors un
ami arrive chez vous à l'improviste en
pleine nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus ce
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
c'est que j'ai fait à balladur se
l'imaginer et loire un ami arrive à
l'improviste chez vous sur la table de
nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus bête
le plus qui trouve mein kampf ou un
godemiché mein kampf quoi balladur mein
kampf aussi mais c'est ce que c'est
qu'un god jeu sûr qu'il sera toujours
qu'ils ont tous manqué à me lâcher un
petit c'est lamentable bien alors est-ce
que vous échangeriez une paralysie
générale si vous êtes tétraplégique pour
le restant de vos jours contre la faim
de la famine au bangladesh
le schip annette je dis oui si je suis
honnête on sait bien que non est ce que
vous êtes en mission qui a ramé ou un
opportuniste qui a eu de la chance j'ai
un ambitieux quai de la chance à butt
pour
alors quand les bienvenus
on part en vacances tous les deux dans
la montagne
il fait très froid il ya beaucoup de
neige à trois mètres de neige on peut
pas aller faire les courses je meurs
vous n'avez plus rien à manger vous me
manger vous commencez par quoi partie
bien dodues legros cusack a donc préféré
jean marie messier va bouffer le clergé
ont passé par des périphrases quiz parle
aussi je vous le dire dans les
connaissent de curé qu'est ce que tu
sais ça s'en va et ça se sent toujours
dernière question jean marie mais si
vous vous laver les cheveux tous les
combien de jours tous les deux jours où
jean marie messier 6/6 points comme chez
hachette littératures 7 chez hachette
ah mais mahut qui va faire du cinéma à
hollywood dans pas longtemps un un
premier rôle dramatique